[Music]
and buying happiness news this was
submitted by dogs are better than humans
Japanese billionaire is running at nine
million dollar basic income experiment
on Twitter oh [ __ ] in America and Japan
is cool you know really yeah I want to
hear what happens yeah okay
because there's two sides to it people
think people aren't happy because a lot
of their basic needs are met so if you
give them some basic income that could
fulfill those needs and then now they
can actually live life without being
stressed out the other side of it is if
you don't earn your own money you'll
never be happy you might lose your drive
yeah yeah because your happiness comes
from accomplishing little goals yeah
well what if it's like it's not enough
money to live off of it's just enough to
like boost it a little boost then what
about that what if my happiness comes
from having more money oh that makes me
happy those are my little goals like
money money this money raining on my
face mm-hmm all right you guys don't get
mad I don't know what the [ __ ] are you
talking about I think I was gone oh I'm
still sitting how we started raccoon
didn't have a striped tail would it be a
squirrel a Japanese billionaire said
he's gonna he's he's donating nine
million dollars to his Twitter followers
to see if it makes them happier so he's
doing this basic income experiment oh
he's really good buying Twitter
followers I want to follow him for sure
because you've actually done this once
before and that tweet is the most
retweeted of all time rule one you have
to follow me damn this was genius yeah
wrote to tell three before attack three
of your friends and have them follow me
yeah so this guy his name is gieux
sukku mozzie alwa sorry if I said it
wrong and so he is the founder we
actually have talked about him in the
past here on JK news
so he's the founder of Japan's largest
fashion retail
website and this is what he looks like
that Uniqlo last time no it's a it's a
Japan right so it's called what are you
laughing that you know I don't know it's
called Zozo town obviously that's seen a
koto town so bored deems him the 22nd
richest person in Japan and so it's not
even the top tier yeah I'm not gonna
take this guy's money ass like a slacker
okay well yeah so anyway when we talked
about him was because he was gonna be
the first tourist signed up to go to the
moon with dance he will be donating
about nine million u.s. dollars to 1,000
of his Twitter followers which will be
about nine thousand one hundred eighteen
dollars per person follow him and
retweet that tweets and so he gave it a
week and he was saying that that he's
pretty whoever received this money will
will have to fill out these surveys
constantly to pretty much let him know
like how oh he also tell him like you
could spend the money however you want I
just want to know how it's affecting
your life I'm out yeah I don't wanna do
yeah that's a lot of homework $9,000 is
this mad a lot in the grand scheme of
things for that type of contingency
plans on how long the surveys like if
it's like a 10 question thing like once
a month like yeah sure I feel like you
should only have the double surveys for
as long as you have the money
Oh in one day I'm done I thought they
would be giving it out like in little
spurts yeah that's why they keep you
having doing the service cuz you give me
that money on top of it boy you ain't
never seen me straight up that's 9 grams
pretty soon for all that work it's just
serving you have to just tell them what
you spent the night grand oh no I'm not
about that more for loser crazy
I like my privacy listen this [ __ ]
here I suppose like we as if it's you
know under 10 questions
no you know you casinos and you sign up
for all the [ __ ] light rewards cards
like I'm like I've done that for like
[ __ ] probably what like a dollar an
award right but if they do they're like
hey 9 grand Ryan's like and what 11
questions I don't think that one
question I'd yeah it's way to throw it
out wait two months wow we're done here
yeah so a lot of people were tweeted it
and they're super excited to find out
but they're saying that the the 1000
winners will be selected at random
through a lottery and they will be
contacted by himself via direct messages
later this month
so like he's cautioning them against
fraudulent messages saying that official
direct messages will be sent to the
winners because I guess in the past like
people pretended to be him and like
people got scammed do you have to live
in Japan that's a good question I don't
know it does seem that he is trying to
create like have this experiment happen
with Japanese citizen hmm but it is on
Twitter like who's stopping you from
from following and well I mean if you
don't speak Japanese gonna be hard to
decipher which tweet google translate
hello see the 1 for 9 grand I think so
the one that has like millions of
retweets okay does he have any goals for
this experiment that he put up like I'm
trying to figure this out I'm trying to
figure that out it's a big survey so he
said that his goal is to test the
premise of a basic income which is the
notion that every citizen should get a
guaranteed regular stipend so he's
saying that normally this idea that the
government should provide these
unconditional stipends but since most
governments have not been trying to do
this he like some wealthy individuals as
this guy have been taking matters into
their own hands injury anxieties
anything yeah it's the gang thing yeah
so and reing he announced that he'd give
away twelve thousand dollars to a random
follower last June and also in Stockton
they are several months into their
18-month basic income experiment that is
sponsored by a nonprofit called economic
security project cool and so they're
showing that the first
badge of data is showing that recipients
are spending the money mostly on food
closing you tittle utility bills which
counters the critics of basic income who
often claim that people will just buy
more stuff yeah more stuff or buy it for
drugs or just not even care to go to
work because they're chilling on this
money but the evidence has not supported
that that's cool yeah I mean it's the
you know it's the it's the Bitcoin thing
right it's like well people use it some
people use it for crimes and so yeah
because some people are shitty about it
that means it's all shitty right it's
like the same idea that's many of course
some people will use it and be [ __ ]
and and then but like they're saying
I mean assume shit's happening with cash
like yeah okay exactly and on the flip
side some people probably that don't
even need it on the wall just give it
double it up for my other cousin who
really needs it right now right there's
probably people doing just so much good
as bad or saving it yeah yeah so I don't
know we'll see how this turns out for
him but a lot of these people are very
excited to get $10,000 I think it'd be
crazy if it wasn't just Japan and you
got a guy getting $9,000 in the third
world country and also they bought a
[ __ ] [ __ ] or you're in a crazy ass first
world country where nine G's is nothing
right and then just seeing how their
quality of life changes but in a thermal
country if you're suddenly balling and
everyone else I was just about to say
that now you're talking yeah because I
was here you don't get back to your own
community you can't fill the survey out
you're [ __ ] it's like the guy who
stole a soccer ball that we heard about
right so I remember what country was guy
stole a soccer ball the the village
hunted him down and then threw a tire on
his neck considered on fire soccer ball
was higher on his neck well I think Bert
Kreischer was talking about he was doing
like a comedy towards thought that's
where I heard it from yeah we both
Austin Rogan cuz I conflated it with a
memory that I had here Wow yeah me too
though yeah he I think he saw like a kid
soccer game or something and he's just
you know beaten feeling like a good
Samaritan he went and bought the whole
team soccer balls and the coach came and
yelled at him and he's like what the
[ __ ] you want all these kids to get
killed and he goes it's just a soccer
ball
he told us here that's right who's now
the comedian oh yeah yeah he shared it
with him and people will die over like
stolen pillow stolen soccer balls in
South America so he's like you I've been
with the tire thing well they they put
much put iers around this guy that stole
a soccer ball or something and then they
lit it on fire just steal his soccer
ball
they caught the guy that stole it jeez
Louise they put the tie around him not
around his neck we put it around him
yeah just stuck in there so they can't
get out I heard around his neck or we
could be mixing up by five stories could
be [ __ ] tennis balls on what the [ __ ]
are we talking about that soccer balls
are flammable I think that stoked I feel
like it's gonna bring a community and
the world together if this good news
fathers keep passing up their money why
me because now people have more
opportunities cause like you're saying
money creates freedom the camera onto
you when you're putting stuff in your
mouth bad timing but it also creates
opportunities and that's [ __ ] dope
money creates opportunities yeah they're
saying that like other countries around
the world are testing this out
it's like Canada they've been
experimenting with basic income for
decades and India why do you take us
along yeah what's going on what is the
results the bud problem honestly it's
it's a it's a question of how it will
affect your economy right yeah nobody
wants to like just suddenly shift
everything cuz it could be it could be
devastating potentially if you [ __ ] it
up like if you give them a thousand a
month like gang proposes what is keep
war not 3,000 months and I think that
that kind of stuff starts to tinsel at
what are the DD or inflation's the
question it might even cause a fight
where like some people like well the
thousands this much you know all in my
state I think it should be state the
story state regulation I'm not even
really against it I'm just really
pointing out the other side like cuz I
know you know if you inflate your
currency like crazy like Zimbabwe
everyone's got trillion dollars doesn't
mean anything so it's just a there is a
point to inflation where it become
[ __ ] yeah that so that's the only
big question I think but I'm afraid to
that if we're not if we are not sending
money to the Middle East and we're
sending money here I don't know that's
kind of a nightmare for the work on a
man kind of offensive the war economy
yeah it'll collapse in on say who's
gonna make all that money
Jerry what's however you gonna do
[Music]